- I'm the one who reacts.
- [Walt Jr.] What the hell is this?
- [Skyler] Hey.
- [Walter] It's veggie
bacon. We're watching
our cholesterol, I guess.
- [Walt Jr.] Not me, I want real bacon.
- (laughing) This feels
like my struggle right now
cause I'm watching my cholesterol.
It's more about decreasing
the amount of saturated fat
in your diet, decreasing
fatty foods, fried foods,
and also at the same time,
increasing your insoluble fiber.
(Walter coughing)
Oh no, don't faint, don't faint.
If you're ever feeling lightheaded,
the first thing you should
do is get down on the floor.
The biggest danger of
passing out is actually
hitting your head and causing
a subdural hemorrhage.
So please, if you're feeling woozy,
get down, get support, call for help.
- [Walter] This is so
embarrassing, I am fine, honestly.
It's just some bug going
around. First my wife had it,
then my son and now me,
it's just like a chest cold.
- See, it's important to
not minimize your symptoms.
Is it possible that he has a chest cold?
Sure, but why in the world
did he pass out from standing?
That needs to be further investigated
and it needs to be
investigated by an ER team
cause he could be having a
heart attack for all they know.
- [Paramedic] Lean
forward for me, would you?
Mr. White, are you a smoker?
- [Walter] No, never.
Why do you ask?
- Okay, this is where these shows,
things get a little ridiculous.
The paramedic with the power
of a stethoscope can diagnose
if there's some really serious
issue going on like lung cancer.
At most, you can hear lung sounds
that can happen as a
result of a pneumonia,
of a viral infection,
an inflammatory process,
a tumor, but you can't
know that without scanning.
So this like devious,
mischievous, look of him going
ah by listening with the
stethoscope is pure ridiculous.
(rumbling)
(ringing)
- [Doctor] Mr. White? Mr. White?
- Yes.
- You understood what
I've just said to you.
- Yes.
Lung cancer. Inoperable.
- I'm really glad they're
showing this part.
When you're receiving bad news,
it's really difficult to comprehend.
You just got a diagnosis that you're
potentially sick for
the rest of your life.
Or going to lose your life
earlier than you expected.
You're not going to be like, okay,
so what are the next
steps of what I should do?
So whenever you deliver
bad news as a doctor,
you have to have the patient come back.
You have to have someone with the patient
to help them understand what's going on.
This part could be the most accurate
part of the first season.
- [Walter] Lung cancer. Inoperable.
- I also don't know how they realize
that it's an inoperable so
quickly, a little bit out there.
I don't know how much
time has passed here.
It's a little inaccurate.
- [Walter] It's just, you've
got mustard on your...
- This is almost like a
dissociation process where
to escape from the bad
news, he's reverting back
to like a childhood state,
or a less serious state
and thinking about the mustard.
Cause that's more fixable
in the given moment.
This does happen. Maybe this is
a little bit more exaggerated though.
- Heisenberg says relax.
(sighs) I'm relaxed. I'm relaxed.
I'm relaxed--
- Oh!
(men grunting)
(exclaiming)
- Wow, damn man, look at that. Look.
- I'm not surprised if
he broke a few knuckles,
hitting a skull on the floor
like that over and over again.
Remember when you punched someone
standing up, their head moves back.
So there's no excess force placed
on your knuckle on your bone.
But when they're laying down
and you're hitting them,
you're essentially hitting the concrete
with your bare knuckle,
you're breaking stuff.
- Heisenberg! What's the matter with you?
- It looks like he's having a seizure.
Sometimes that can
happen with brain bleeds.
- [Walter] There's, there's no pulse.
- If there's no pulse you've gotta start
chest compressions, chest
compressions, chest compressions.
- Do something.
- [Walter] Do something?
He needs an ambulance.
He needs a hospital.
- Do something! You're
smart, right? Do that thing!
- He knows that thing!
But the thing is really
meant to buy your time.
It doesn't actually restart the heart.
The point of doing the thing
so that the ambulance has time
to get there and actually intervene.
- Beans.
- Castor beans.
- So what are we gonna do with them?
- We are going to process them into ricin.
- You actually process it into castor oil
and the residue has ricin in it.
- Rice and beans.
- Ricin.
- He said rice and beans.
I forgot about this.
- It's an extremely effective poison.
It's toxic in small doses.
Also fairly easy to
overlook during an autopsy.
- It is checked for on
autopsy's by the way,
This his fugue state?
- What's the last thing you remember?
- Well, I was driving home.
I think.
- From what I remember, he's faking this
and he's doing a really good job.
- Isn't it possible
that this had something
to do with all the
prescriptions I've been taking.
- In order to diagnose a
medication side effect like that
it really has to be a
diagnosis of exclusion
where you rule everything else out
that could cause this
dissociative state of his,
and then you can then
blame the medication,
but you absolutely do need
a psychiatric consult here.
- Would you tell me about
patient confidentiality?
- It's very straightforward.
Without your permission
I can't disclose anything
you tell me to anyone.
- What about my family?
- Not to your family, not to
the police, not to anyone.
The only exception would be if
you threatened to kill someone,
then I'd be able to tell that
person. But only that person.
- Protected health information is
really important in the cases of
homicidal or suicidal ideation.
We do alert the authorities or loved ones.
I don't know that in
a homicidal situation,
if you threaten to harm one other person,
they only tell that person.
I think they have to notify
the authorities as well.
- Jesse, wake up.
Jesse, wake up.
- That is a needle and a syringe
likely to have been used for narcotics.
(choking)
Oh no. If someone's
throwing up on their back,
you have to put them on their side
in order to help clear their airway.
Because if they can't protect their
airway cause they're unconscious,
they can aspirate the vomit, choke, die.
(choking)
- No, no, no.
- Dude. You got to act.
And that's unfortunately how
a lot of overdoses do end.
Someone ends up aspirating
and choking to death.
(gun shots)
Oh, that's got to hurt.
- Oh, that's gotta hurt.
(breaking glass)
- That's one way to crush your femur,
create a fatty embolism, make it go to
your lungs and you just die instantly.
(tires squealing)
Also don't forget, crush injuries
release a massive amount
of electrolytes into the
bloodstream from the damaged cells
and create a complete mashup of your
electrical system in the body,
which most importantly
happens in the heart.
Therefore it could be lethal.
(horn honking)
How come like bad guys in
movies always walk so calmly.
Like they're never in a rush.
Like my guy, you don't
think the cops are coming
after you just lit up a parking lot?
(horn beeping)
- No, muy fácil.
- Yeah. The bad guy's not in a rush.
He lit up a supermarket.
He's not in a rush.
He's getting his ax.
An ax to the head is
incompatible with life.
(gunshot)
GSW to the head, incompatible with life.
Thought I'd, thought
I'd let you guys know.
- No, impossible.
Salud.
(both speaking Spanish)
(water running)
(man gagging)
- Induction of vomiting
for poison can work.
It has to happen very rapidly.
Remember ricin gets absorbed
very quickly into your mucus membranes.
That's why it can affect
you even through your eyes.
Can you make it less
lethal if you vomit it up?
Yeah, probably.
(upbeat music)
(glass breaking)
- Tu!
- I feel like if this was true ricin
there would be a lot of vomiting here.
Those are Pyxis machines.
Those look very legitimate.
- Visto.
- It's like a full
operating room in there.
- Vamanos.
- Those hospital beds are
so extremely expensive.
You have no idea.
- Rapiddo, rapiddo!
- I mean you have to intubate him.
You have to make sure
his heart's not stopped.
These are the most crucial moments
in order to help save someone's life.
Oh, I have no idea what he
just squirted into his mouth.
- (exclaiming)
- All right. And she's
bagging way too fast.
When you're bagging, you need to bag
at the same rate that
a person would breathe.
If we're at rest, you're bagging
at pow, pow, pow, pow, pow,
you could actually
create a bigger problem.
They're doing an intubation it looks like.
Some leads that aren't sticking well,
starting IVs, all good stuff.
They're doing dialysis to
get rid of the poison. Wow.
That's a blood transfusion,
O negative blood, universal donor.
Oh!
- Gracias.
- I love that he's chilling
already. Not realistic.
(bell rings)
- (exclaims)
- (explosion) Oh!
Kaboom.
- (alarm ringing)
- Kaboom. Not surviving that.
- Oh, maybe I was wrong.
I love how the staff are in no concern
that there is another explosion
that's about to happen.
- (alarm ringing)
- Oh, okay. Yeah. He's not fixing his tie.
That's ridiculous. This isn't Batman.
Did you know that I'm a YouTube boxer now?
Click here to check that out.
As always stay happy.
And first I beat, then I treat.
(punching noises)
(upbeat music)